pour ce premier week-end de confinement
les yvelinois ont décidé de sortir tout
en respectant leur ayant des 10 km
imposées par les autorités à plaisir ce
dimanche de nombreux promeneurs ont
investi le parc du château objectif
s'offrir une bouffée d'oxygène en
famille ou entre amis fait une petite
balade pour profiter un peu de l'ère des
copines
bien sûr on a vu toutes les trois dans
le même immeuble donc ça pose aucun
problème
certains ont également profité de cette
sortie sans limitation de durée pour
faire un peu de sport une partie de
pétanque s'organise dans le parc
d'autres n'ont pas hésité à enfourcher
leur bicyclette à la je veux faire du
vélo la du vélo tout le long du parc là
et puis j'ai peut-être m'arrêter un
petit peu voilà prendre un peu le soleil
a vu qu'il est encore là voilà profiter
un petit peu ça va faire du bien j'ai
besoin de verdure des espaces
de me balader du sport également à
voisins le bretonneux ce dimanche matin
des enfants font du roller dans cette
heure de jeu ici à 50 mètres cette
famille joue au rugby sur l'herbe depuis
plus d'une heure sinon resteraient entre
quatre murs dans le salon on aura un peu
en rond donc oui non c'est très bien de
pouvoir s'aérer en plus ce n'est pas
normal des espaces verts autour de la
maison
on en profite ici donc ça fait du bien
ça fait beaucoup de bien même que je
peux aller au collège
malgré le confinement ouais ça paye bien
quelques mètres plus loin le ballon à
changer de forme et les activités se
pratiquent toujours en famille on est en
train de faire un tube oh t'as quand tu
ferais dans le stade c'est moins
qu'avant confinement là on s'entraîne on
fait des coups francs des tirs des
matchs si on s'entraîne pas on pourra
perdre son niveau
ce nouveau confinement devrait durer au
minimum pendant quatre semaines